có gặp thương đềng giữa tổng thống mấy đương nân tròng và tổng thống 1,5 đêm mẹ phu chiên.
Giờ kinh sĩnh xác ngày mạnh tảng tại Alaska đang chử thành tâm điểm chân cảnh của tế.
Phó chủ tịch khuổi đồng ăn nguyên gà điểm biệt vẻ đép cáu vộn,
liên mình cho ông đang tìm cách căn thiệp.
Thì nhiều nhà lãnh đạo cho ông kêu hỏi Washington mừng tổng thống uc quên nhà
vóa lo điểm biê gên gây tham dự.
Và gây xưa gái bộng mắt gà và phản nhiều bộ.
Chục khi đó, tổng thống tròng tế lộ, tại có sự chào đổi lãnh thổ,
nhận mang lại lợi ý chục cả hai bên, sau chưa công bủ chí tiếp.
Lợp chương ngủ kế vẫn nhất quán không chương nhận bất kì thổ thận nào,
liên quán tự lãnh thổ mà không có sự tham gia của quen em.
Con thằng ngoài giáo ra tăng kì ấy, ông bởi quen gia xem đây là bấn đề ăn nguyên chính lược của chủ ông.
Con ngàn có cái đường thái này là anh đi phán hoại đàn phán.
Thó phản nữ mới cho thấy tiến chình tìm kiến hoà mình vẫn và phản nhiều giáo cảnh chính trị,
và lợi ý chục khán.